you guys house newlywed life it's great
but it's also like non-stop we want to
like live newlywed life we've been just
like doing so much
we just want like a little date night we
haven't had a date night center since
our honeymoon yeah well actually Chicago
no it's been it's been pretty awesome
and so kind of getting back into the
whole grind of things I think we
appreciated the honeymoon a lot more
because I talked about this on the
podcast a lot the fact that we spend so
much time together but I don't think we
spend as much quality time as we should
and on the honeymoon we spend a lot of
quality time you just connect and you
just hang out and so I think we need to
really put effort into making sure that
we just hang out and not everything is
you know work so being a Hollywood
couple you know it's a little date night
tonight we're going to see a movie
moving way too long that's our favorite
date night they say that the first year
of marriage is the hardest are you guys
feeling that no I feel like the first
year of marriage must be the hardest for
people that didn't live together when
they were engaged because we don't feel
like it's that much different yeah like
I know exactly what drives me nuts about
him in the house but we're really even
really working through that what do you
what drives you nuts in the house like
um just like little things that he'll
like put in a place that I don't
necessarily think that's the greatest
spot for that little memento for me
right now and it's just you know I think
we have different styles when it comes
to redoing things I like to take one
thing at a time where Ashley's like
let's just do it all at once and that's
very chaotic and sometimes it gets me
overwhelmed
yeah but then sometimes I'm like an
action figure isn't the core such a dude
thing you need a dude room yeah he has a
dude Raj yeah to see it needs to be a
garage
so much news coming out of your world
you guys Tyler and Gigi have broken up
yes can't believe it so we've heard it
really it burned hot and burned out fast
it was so intense that he was going to
have funerals with her like that isn't
it she went to Grandma's funeral and
they've already broke I was like they
must really think it's it I know that
was like really really crazy like I want
to know what happened to make it break
off so soon after the funeral which was
just such a big moment yeah it's really
sad I was really hoping for Tyler and
Gigi I don't know why it was just cool
story Tyler and Hannah could now have a
chance know that they're never no no I'm
surprised she hasn't fall unfollowed him
on Instagram what he did that was sleazy
a little bit what if Hannah still has
feelings you know she doesn't have
feelings anymore after that I'd be fair
who knows how long Tyler and Gigi were
talking maybe Tyler and Gigi were
already hanging out by the time that
like the after the final rose I'm
already may have been talking we're all
speculating here so maybe I mean I know
maybe you know Tyler's like hey I'm
already with someone okay and then maybe
now he's single but I've heard that
something like actually of content Nick
he's like in G cute like right now he is
he they crowned him like the king of
bachelor nation and Juke you today he is
the king of bachelor nation right now
that dude now but it's in six months
it'll be someone else be pilot beat
he'll be havin girls up in the windmill
I don't know if you can view the the
entity that he Key's he went from
bachelors to supermodel and that is like
next-level yeah he like left the
franchise next question is so I heard
that the reason that Mike wasn't made
the bachelor is because he's boring true
or false
no he's absolutely not boring happen how
did it pilot peek at it aren't are you
excited are we not I feel like it always
turns out good no it's always turns out
well every bachelor you know no matter
what the buzz is around them when
they're announced the season always
turns out well and
I'm not really sure why it wasn't Mike
it comes down to those interviews that
they do with like the whole deciding
team this time last year everybody was
saying Colton was gonna be a bust and
his season was awesome and then they
said the same thing about Hanna
they were like Hanna the girl that can't
talk and then her season was awesome so
you guys ever hop back in or have you
thought about shopping like us together
life reality show I was like hot back
into bachelor it's gonna be interesting
I have it I have the thing that I think
they should jump up on it'd be an
amazing race but for the couple's of
bachelor nation and we always have
things going on so we'll who knows what
the future has such a good idea and
that's on CBS Phil are you listening to
me right now it's Kelsey from et let's
have a bachelor couples amazing race but
like Amazing Race has already coupled up
so just like have couples and I think it
would be really funny couples that come
out of bachelor nation having to like
just be dropped in the woods and be like
all right here you go no more fat for
fun here you go
tagline could be we're not in the
mansion anymore okay okay bye